so mr. Branson what is your take on the
UN summit was it what was it worth the
effort it hasn't moves things forward at
all if any if anything it's move things
backwards so so it's very very
disappointing and it was the drug
enforcement people of the UN that you
know the drew up the rules and they
haven't taken into account advice from
civil society advice scientific advice
that shows that if you can treat drugs
as a health problem not a criminal
problem you can get on top of the
problem but if you continue to
criminalize it will continue to have
another 50 years of failed drug policy
it seems that the this UN agreement is
extra actually contra productive it is
counterproductive I mean what the global
commissioner drug policy been urging
countries and states to do is to
experiment with new approaches and you
know countries like Portugal that have
experimented with new approaches and
ignored the UN have largely got on top
of their drug problems say in 2001 said
that anybody in our country who has a
drug problem we will not criminalize you
we will help you and and they went all
out to help those people and the
prevalence of of heroin for instances
has dropped by something like ninety
percent so you know in America you've
obviously got medical marijuana centers
cropping up you've got legalization in
some states we have not seen an
explosion of use in fact quite the
reverse and and instead of the money
that's derived from the sale of
marijuana going into the underworld it's
gone towards education and you know
alcoholic centers for you know people
who've got alcohol problems and and and
become much more beautiful to much
better use what can be done on an
international level to really find
solution if it's not the UN if we need
individual governments to be brave and
to be bold I mean the chairman of our
commission Ruth Dreyfus she used to run
Switzerland
she introduced needle exchange programs
in Switzerland where people where people
could come where they could get their
get their heroin fix that with a clean
needle so that they didn't catch HIV or
hepatitis C and and and it and it works
and it's a humane way of dealing with
people and we just need other leaders
throughout the world to do the right
thing thank you very much very much cool